ja ich habe ihn erstmal ein Bild
gebracht meiner Hochschule weil man da
sage ich mal spezifische Bedingungen
vorfindet und zwar sehen Sie hier so
einige Gebäude der Fachhochschule und
dort unten befinden sich schon drei
uniformierte gestalten die schauen wir
uns nämlich im Folgenden dann etwas
genauer an das sind nämlich unsere
Studierenden der Polizei an unserer
Hochschule ist die Polizeiausbildung
eben ein ganz wichtiges Element der
größte Fachbereich und da sind wir jetzt
auch schon bei der Ausgangslage und zwar
ist es so dass im Fachbereich
polizei-situationstrainings Curricula
verankert sind was ist ein
situationstraining überhaupt das werden
Sie sich wahrscheinlich fragen in der
polizeilichen Arbeit ist es so dass sehr
viele Situationen passieren ich sag mal
im Straßenverkehr wenn es um
Straßenkontrollen geht bis hin eben zu
polizeilichen Einsätzen und genau dafür
werden im situationstrainings
durchgeführt damit die Studierenden dann
nachher
im Berufsalltag also gut bestehen können
und entsprechende Verhaltensmuster parat
haben ja Ziel der situationstrainings
ist somit die Vermittlung situativ
angemessener Handlungen also die
Vermittlung von Handlungsfähigkeit oder
die Stärkung von Handlungsfähigkeit
ja wir haben des weiteren die folgende
Ausgangslage gehabt und zwar im Frühjahr
2021 ist an der Fachhochschule das so
gewesen dass wir hier nur digital
leeren durften sie wissen ja worauf
woraus das sozusagen erfolgte das ganze
wir haben da Hygienekonzepte und so
weiter und es wurde eben angestrebt also
wirklich alles möglichst digital
umzusetzen
dennoch war es so dass
situationstrainings natürlich immer
regelmäßig auf dem Lehrplan stehen
hier noch einmal eine Übersicht zu
dieser Problematik der wir uns
darstellen mussten im Fachbereich
Polizei und zwar sehen Sie also die
situationspraxis diesen praxisnah
sie sind anwendungsorientiert lehrreich
sie müssen eigentlich immer sage ich mal
direkt in der Präsenz natürlich
normalerweise erfolgen
und dahingegen hatten wir dann eben die
Situation des online-unterrichts der
dezentral ist virtuell und individuell
also eigentlich etwas was man kaum
miteinander vereinbaren kann das Dach
jedenfalls viele viele Lehrende und
kamen dann auf mich zu aus dem
Fachbereich und wollten sich dann mit
mir beraten dahingehend wie man denn
diese situationstrainings vielleicht
doch noch irgendwie digital durchführen
können
der Wunsch der Lehrenden war das
sozusagen die situationstrainings eben
trotz dieser diesen digital Setting
durchgeführt werden könnten und das eben
diese Handlungskompetenz der
Studierenden darin auch entwickelt würde
ja da fragt man sich natürlich dann als
hochschuledidaktikerin ja wunderbar ihr
habt tolle Wünsche wie kann ich jetzt
euch dabei begleiten und dadurch dass
ich mich ja mit der Digitalisierung an
der Fachhochschule beschäftige
haben wir da eine Lösung gefunden jetzt
aber zunächst noch mal einmal zum Team
ich möchte da noch mal mich besonders
bedanken auch bei diesen Lehrenden weil
sie mir also auch Einblick geboten haben
in dieses Projekt sage ich mal in ihr
lehrprojekt und zwar waren das Frau Dr
Anne Melzer Henriette Bohnen Herr
Clemens lange Herr Dr Wolfram karg Frau
Heike Wegener Frau Doreen Rehfeldt Frau
Alina Arnhold und herr Michael Gutknecht
also doch ein ganz Wahrheit
aufgestelltes Team der Fachgruppe 2 die
das Thema Führung sozial und
Gesellschaftswissenschaften sowie auch
Sprachen verantwortet
und jetzt kommen wir zu der Lösung die
wir da entwickeln durften und zwar kamen
wir darauf
es einfach einmal mit einem Szenario zu
probieren man muss dazu sagen in diesen
situationstrainings Spielen Szenario
Arbeit also später eine sehr große Rolle
aber viele der Trainings Erfolgen im
Szenarien in polizeilichen Szenarien sie
können sich vorstellen also vielleicht
ich sag mal ein Dieb den man verfolgen
muss beispielsweise oder eine
Verkehrskontrolle also die dann auch
tatsächlich mit echten Bürgern teilweise
durchgeführt wird also deswegen diese
Idee wir wollen einzelnario dann war
natürlich die Lösungsidee wenn wir das
machen wollen digital lasst es uns
Hybrid umsetzen und dann war auch noch
die Frage der Thematik also natürlich
ist es Curricula auch festgelegt welche
Themen in den situationstrainings
durchgeführt werden und wir haben da
unter anderem eben das Thema häusliche
Gewalt dann auch forciert
man muss sich das bei dem Szenario so
vorstellen dass der der Ausgangspunkt
war Polizei der Zukunft also die Story
ist im Prinzip das
2030 die Polizei über Videotelefonie in
allen Haushalten der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
vorhanden ist also dass man sozusagen
aus der eigenen Wohnung heraus schnell
Kontakt aufnehmen kann und gesehen wird
das war sozusagen der Hintergrund und
das wurde auch den Studierenden
entsprechend dann
erzählt während des Szenarios
jetzt zum Konzept also wie gestaltet
sich das jetzt ganz konkret
wir haben also im Prinzip Webkonferenzen
als Ausgangspunkt gewählt
wir sind davon ausgegangen dass es ein
schauspielernden Dozentin oder Dozent
geben müssen
der oder diejenige müsse dann im Prinzip
dieses Szenario mit jeweils einer
Studentin oder einem Studenten
durchführen
dann sind wir davon ausgegangen das
Ganze kann sozusagen dieser
schauspielerische aktive Part nicht
bewältigen diese Auswertung und
Beobachtung deshalb benötigen wir also
auch noch eine Dozentin oder ein Dozent
der das ganze per Webcam sozusagen
beobachtet seine eigene Webcam aber
ausgeschaltet lässt und die dann erst in
der Auswertungsphase einschaltet
und zeitlich der zeitliche Rahmen ist
recht knapp bemessen da komme ich aber
auch noch zu warum das werden sie noch
erwähnen und zwar haben wir dann
festgelegt dass es 15 Minuten sozusagen
Gespräch oder
Szenario sozusagen
vollzogen würde und 15 Minuten dann
Auswertung also insgesamt eine halbe
Stunde
ja wie haben wir das jetzt geplant
da kommen wir jetzt erstmal zum
technischen Setting und zwar haben wir
auf der einen Seite linker Hand sehen
Sie die schauspielernden und auch
beobachtenden Lehrenden also jeweils
immer zwei Personen wie so ein Team und
die sind dann im Prinzip in Interaktion
mit der Studierenden oder dem
Studierenden im Homeoffice
die Planung war auch dass wir einen
gewissen Zeitraum dafür ja also durchaus
festsetzen mussten um das so durchführen
zu können und das war dann der erste
dritte bis
11.3.2021 und pro Session wurden eben 30
Minuten veranschlagt so wie ich das ja
eben schon erläutert hatte
insgesamt muss ich sagen und das ist
auch der Grund warum das so knapp
bemessen war insgesamt handelt es sich
nämlich um sechs Seminargruppen und pro
Seminargruppe haben wir hier ungefähr so
um die 25 Studierenden also das heißt es
war schon wirklich eine Menge an
Studierenden die das gesamte durchlaufen
haben
die Teilnahme insgesamt waren in etwa
140 Studierende es waren einige auch
krank
auch mit kovi zu Hause und so weiter
also und von daher 140 Studierende die
also direktes durchlaufen haben ja und
wie lange hat das insgesamt gedauert es
hat fünf Tage gedauert und es gab zwei
Teams hier habe ich einmal den Plan
rechte Hand so dass Sie also sehen
können wieder so der Einsatz geplant
wurde der einzelnen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie sehen hier an der Station 1
Frau Wegener und Herrn Gutknecht und an
der Station 2 Frau Melzer und Frau
Rehfeld
und dann sieht man die zeitliche Taktung
eben in diesem
halbstündigen Takt mit Pause und so
weiter und je nachdem eben sie sehen
also die Durchnummerierung von 1 bis 11
und oder teilweise 12 ja auch und dann
entsprechend auch die Zuordnung der
Studierenden die habe ich hier natürlich
geschwärzt ja aber die sind dann
entsprechend auch in dem jeweiligen Slot
ja angedacht und ja so wurde das dann
durchgeführt und das muss ich sagen also
da auch wirklich dadurch den höchsten
Respekt vor den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es war anscheinend auch sehr sehr
anstrengend sie können sich vorstellen
also wenn man eine halbe Stunde hat für
Szenario und Auswertung und das wirklich
in diesen in dieser Taktung um überhaupt
durch die Gruppen hindurch zu kommen
dann ist man wirklich also abends
geschafft ja nach so nach solchen fünf
Tagen also das ist wirklich danach
brauchen die wirklich ein gutes
Wochenende zu Erholung
kommen wir jetzt also auch noch mal zu
den konkreten
umsetzungsaspekten die Web-Konferenzen
erfolgten über Microsoft Teams weil das
auch bei uns an der Fachhochschule das
System ist in dem wir Hybrid und
überhaupt digital miteinander arbeiten
und interagieren
das ganze wurde allerdings nicht
bewertet also es blieb unbenotet das war
sozusagen auch dem geschuldet weil es
eben hybrides unten versuch also wir
wollten nicht dann gleich Noten vergeben
für dieses neue Setting und von daher
gibt es erstmal unbenotet und unbewertet
und eine Bedingung gab es und zwar
technisch gesehen dass alle Studierenden
natürlich Webcams benötigt haben
das weiteren war dann auch noch etwas
was auch eine Rolle spielt bei diesem
Szenarios also hier ging es ja
vornehmlich auch um häusliche Gewalt
also wurde tatsächlich geschminkt und
kosmetisiert also es gab richtig
jemanden der da so ein bisschen die
Maske übernommen hat also das sah schon
richtig schlimm aus teilweise also es
waren ja Lehrende die sich als
Schauspieler dann zur Verfügung gestellt
haben man muss dazu sagen dass sogar die
Seminargruppen diese Lehrenden schon
kann also es waren keine unbekannten
Personen das ist jetzt noch mal
vielleicht wichtig wenn wir nachher zur
Emotionalität des ganzen kommen also es
war die Lehrenden waren allen bekannt
und wurden dann aber so hergerichtet
dass sie richtig grausig aussahen
und es gab auch Requisiten an die Hand
also je nach es gab da so kleine
Drehbücher für die Szenarios und
entsprechend natürlich Requisiten wie
hier zum Beispiel genannt eine Babypuppe
die dann zum Beispiel Frau Dr Melzer so
auf dem Arm hier als sozusagen Mutter
mit Kind in häuslicher gewaltssituation
und die Szenario Hintergründe also diese
Raum Hintergründe das kennen Sie ja wir
sehen das ja hier auch bei ihnen das ist
teilweise dann andere Hintergründe gibt
also wir haben diese Funktion sozusagen
genutzt bei Microsoft Teams dass man den
Hintergrund durch eine Grafik ersetzen
kann und da wurden dann verschiedene
Raum Hintergründe eben genutzt um das
Szenario auch besser abbilden zu können
also wie so eine Art Kulisse ich habe
hier mal diese Kulissen das sind also
diese Kulissen die tatsächlich auch
verwendet wurden also hier so ein ich
sag mal Schlafzimmer im Beton Look
dann haben wir hier ein Badezimmer somit
einem was auch interessant war eben im
dachobergeschoss also wo man nicht so
schnell irgendwie heraus können was da
auch eine Rolle gespielt hat und wir
haben hier eine Wohnung ja ich weiß gar
nicht ob er das so sagen darf aber die
möglicherweise einer Messi Familie oder
einer Person die Messi mäßig unterwegs
ist
ja gehören könnte also recht
unaufgeräumt sagen wir mal
es gab zwei Phasen dieses Szenario
Settings und zwar einerseits natürlich
erstens diese Durchführung des Szenarios
und die erfolgte tatsächlich so dass das
kennen Sie ja so wie hier auch in den
Online Meetings das man also sozusagen
reingeht in das Meeting und dann ging es
sofort los ja und zwar muss man sich
vorstellen also der Schauspieler der
oder die schauspielernde
warteten auf den neuen Studierenden der
dann da kommen würde oder die da kommen
würde und waren sofort in diesen in
dieser Szenerie dann drin und das war
natürlich für die Studierenden die
erstmal gar nicht wussten was sie da
erwartete also das wurde ihm nicht
vorher vermittelt ja so wie es in der
Polizei auch ist man kommt in einen in
einem eine Wohnung und da bietet sich
dann irgendetwas da und man muss da
entsprechend interagieren und handeln
also so war es da auch dass also nicht
schon vorher gewusst wurde worum es da
eigentlich genau geht und sie waren
sozusagen sofort hineingeworfen das muss
man dazu sagen genau und das dauerte
dann insgesamt 15 Minuten in denen die
Studierenden dann entsprechend handeln
mussten je nachdem was eben diese Person
Ihnen an Informationen gegeben hat
mussten sie dann Tipps geben wie sie
sich dann verhalten sollte gegen
Aggressoren und so weiter und die zweite
Phase ist die Auswertung des Szenarios
das ist jetzt hier nur so dargestellt
eigentlich waren auch die beiden
Lehrenden sozusagen natürlich online
zugeschaltet also nicht so eng
beieinander sie wissen corona-konform
ist dieser Abstand hier denke ich nicht
der hier dargestellt ist aber nur um das
so zu verdeutlichen also die Auswertung
erfolgte dann und dabei schaltete sich
dann die beobachtende Lehrperson zu mit
ihrer Webcam so dass man also gemeinsam
in den Dialog gehen konnte also auch
noch mal 15 Minuten Auswertung und
interessant fand ich auch dass die
Kolleginnen dann auch die Auswertung so
ein bisschen
geteilt haben und zwar einerseits gab es
eine Auswertung eben natürlich mit dem
oder der Studierenden und dann gab es
auch noch Fragen zur Auswertung des
Szenarios also sie wollten auch erfahren
wie das jetzt angekommen ist ob das
realistisch rüber kam oder wobei sie
eine Irritation gespürt haben und also
das war auch ganz interessant sozusagen
da davon auch dann zu erfahren also wie
sozusagen auch dieser emotionale
Eintritt der Studierenden in das
Szenario erfolgte ja also das hat die
Kollegin besonders interessiert man muss
dazu sagen sie sind auch sehr
Psychologie lastig also es sind
Psychologen und von daher war das
natürlich spannend
kommen wir also zu diesem interessanten
Thema der Emotionalität in einem solchen
Setting ja also es gab zum Beispiel also
es hat mich ganz erstaunt es gab
wirklich keinerlei Verweigerung der
Studierenden ich hatte vermutet dass es
vielleicht Studierende gäbe die damit
nicht so ganz konform gehen mit dieser
Art des Lehrens aber nein also sie haben
alle mitgemacht
und im Feedback der Studierenden gab es
zwei große Aspekte die da hervortraten
und zwar positiv wurde gesagt dass also
diese Ermöglichung überhaupt der
handlungserprobung für sie so wichtig
ist im Studium dass sie sich also
gefreut haben dass die Lehrenden ja
diesen Versuch einfach gestartet haben
dass im virtuellen Szenario zu tun und
auch eben in diesem übrigens Setting das
Negativ wurde dann allerdings bewertet
eben dass es tatsächlich eine künstliche
Situation ist also das ist schwierig ist
sich dann wirklich emotional auf
einzulassen dann war das natürlich so
dass meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann
noch mal nachgebohrt haben und gefragt
haben inwieweit sie sich wirklich
emotional darauf einlassen konnten und
es ist ganz interessant das Feedback der
Studierenden ergab also das lediglich
nur fünf Prozent sich gar nicht darauf
emotional einlassen konnten
zehn Prozent taten sich da so ein wenig
schwer aber 85 Prozent konnten sich da
wirklich sehr sehr gut drauf einlassen
und wir haben das jetzt nicht sozusagen
per Video aufgenommen was ich sehr
schade finde also da hätten wir uns
jetzt die
ja das einholen müssen von den
Studierenden die Erlaubnis also es ist
wirklich schade weil ich hätte gerne
gesehen ab welchem Punkt jemand anfängt
zu schwitzen und richtig dabei zu sein
ja denn meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die haben wirklich geschildert dass das
also relativ schnell ging also innerhalb
von 1 2 3 Minuten waren einige
Studierende schon Schweiß gebadet und
als ob sie wirklich ich sag mal in
diesem Badezimmer steht Stunden ja oder
in dem Schlafzimmer oder in der Wohnung
und das belegt natürlich dass also diese
virtuelle Welt doch gerade von der
Generation dann möglicherweise auch ganz
gut ja akzeptiert ist und wir hatten das
ja eben gerade in dem Vortrag auch
dieses Thema das habe ich hier nämlich
noch mal mit eingebaut also diese
Generation Z online ich fand diesen
Begriff eben auch sehr sehr schön das
passt tatsächlich ganz gut weil da
stellt sich also mir auch die Frage ja
wie on live sind sie also was ist
sozusagen für sie dann doch nicht ganz
so künstlich was man selber vielleicht
als künstlich empfinden würde vielleicht
ist es tatsächlich ein
generationsthema das konnten wir jetzt
leider nicht so richtig erheben bei den
Studierenden gibt es natürlich auch
ältere Studierende also wir haben in der
Polizei Studierende die ich sag mal bei
Eintritt ins Studium 34 sind maximal
also das ist sozusagen die maximale das
maximale Alter und wir haben natürlich
dann auch wenn es in Richtung Ausbildung
geht wir haben auch Ausbildung hier da
geht es bis zu 16 Jahre also 16 bis 34
ist so die Spanne und im Studium
natürlich dann eher so von 18 19 bis 34
und da ist eben die Frage ob wirklich
diese Generation Set dann möglicherweise
sich da auch viel schneller drauf
eingelassen hat
ja Frau Dr melzer hat sich auch dazu
noch mal so spezifisch hier geäußert ich
zitiere sie haben sich zwar nicht
emotional eingelassen aber dennoch
wertgeschätzt in der virtuellen
Situation das Gespräch am Laufen halten
zu müssen also das bezieht sich jetzt
insbesondere eben auf die weniger
emotional eingebundenen Studierenden die
trotzdem aber motiviert waren
mitzuspielen und dieses mitspielen im
Szenario ist natürlich ganz entscheidend
sei es nun in Präsenz oder eben virtuell
hier auch noch mal eine Reflektion
Zitat es ist nicht der optimale Weg aber
wert es auszuprobieren man muss um es
bewerten zu können es einfach einmal
durchführen wir wussten nicht wie es
verlaufen würde aber wir haben uns auf
den Flow eingelassen aufgetretene
Probleme wie zum Beispiel bei zwei
Studierenden technische Probleme haben
wir ein Flow bearbeitet man sollte es
unbedingt ausprobieren
also als Fazit lässt sich feststellen
dass diese realen Sessions zwar nicht
also die sind unersetzbar ja also gerade
in der polizeilichen Arbeit spielt ja
auch Körperlichkeit eine ganz große
Rolle das war hier auch ein Manko das
haben auch viele Studierende dann auch
geäußert dass das natürlich im
virtuellen Raum so nicht geht
obwohl wenn ich jetzt so an den
vorhergehenden Vortrag denke ist es
vielleicht doch irgendwann so dass wir
diese Brillen aufhaben also VR Brillen
und man dann wirklich das Gefühl hat man
ist da mittendrin aber ich sag mal in
diesen zweidimensionalen virtuellen
Sessions ist es eher unersetzbar aber
auch Hybride Szenarios können sich zur
Handlungskompetenz Entwicklungen
durchaus anbieten und da muss man eben
abwägen auch didaktische abwägen ob das
auch für das jeweilige Fach vielleicht
möglich ist ob das auch für das Thema
passt also wie gesagt nicht jedes Thema
funktioniert also gut beispielsweise
diese Verkehrskontrollen die ja Outdoor
stattgefunden haben und kein Problem
während der corona-phase waren die würde
ich jetzt auch wirklich auf der Straße
dann belassen ja also da macht es dann
keinen Sinn Verkehrskontrollen an so
Hybriden Autos sage ich mal
zu vollziehen könnte man natürlich
machen so videomäßig aber passt dann
vielleicht nicht ganz
und jetzt vielleicht zur Diskussion weil
es mich auch sehr interessiert wie es
bei ihnen ist ob sie vielleicht selber
Erfahrung gemacht haben
Verhaltens- und handlungsorientierte
Lehre im hybrid-szenario können sie sich
das für ihr Fach auch vorstellen oder
haben Sie bereits eigene Erfahrungen
damit gemacht
ich ja ich bedanke mich und wir gehen
gleich in die Diskussion und ich wünsche
Ihnen einen schönen und insbesondere
experimentellen